[Music]
brandi is with us in sacramento hi
brandi welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave it's so nice to talk to you you
too what's up um
so me and my husband plan on leaving
california in five years when i can
retire early from the state and start
collecting my pension
so we have sold two of our three homes
and have that money just sitting in the
bank
and with interest rates expected to rise
and inflation going through the roof
where should we invest that money for
the next five years we want to have it
you know available when we're ready to
buy out of state yeah but if it were me
i would put a portion of it if not all
of it in just a simple index fund an s p
500 fund
okay
now what that is is a fund that follows
the stock market exactly
it's not going to do better than the
market or worse than the market it's
going to be exactly following the market
now not the dow jones industrial average
but it's going to follow what the real
market is doing the overall markets the
top 500 stocks according to standard and
poor and that's the snp 500 okay
and so i do that when i'm parking money
and
uh it's a conservative mid-range mutual
fund investment
it's very predictable
and it has no commissions on it so
you're not going to get you don't you i
don't mind paying a commission when i'm
going long term but when i'm just
sticking in there for a little while and
i'll do that sometimes for a year or two
years not even five but when you do it
for five you're pretty safe because the
market's track record over five-year
periods of time is very very good to
make some money and you don't have to
make much here to do better than
the bank because the bank just doesn't
pay anything
yeah
and the good news is you're investing
basically in companies that are
inflation
meaning the the things that they make
and that they provide are the prices are
going up on them so they're reflected in
your returns so that's what you call a
hedge against inflation when you are
investing in the things that are the
elements of inflation
that makes sense
yes it does so you know but now here's
the thing you can what you ought to do
is you ought to uh do a little bit of
study on that and see what the track
record is
and say okay how many periods how many
five year periods of the s p
make money and how many lose money
and you go oh oh you know i could lose
money yeah you could
uh but what's the what's the likelihood
based on that i don't know that number
off the top of my head by the way
um
it's the vast majority make money though
probably 90 percent of the five year
periods make money but ten percent of
the time you could lose money well based
on that i don't wanna put it all in
there i'm gonna put some in cds okay
that's fine but cds are gonna pay you
one two percent even if rates go up
and uh the rates are not going to go up
to the inflationary levels because we're
sitting you know we may see some
double-digit inflation and so if you're
not making at least
10 percent on your money you're not
going to be ahead of inflation
follow me
mm-hmm so it's you're taking the risk of
inflation kicking your butt if you don't
invest aggressively enough if you invest
too aggressive you're taking the risk of
actually losing the money does that make
sense
yes
so that's that's why i do that's what i
would do with it it's what i do with
mine
i just park it there and then any money
that it makes you don't have any it
hardly has any turnover ratio so there's
hardly any taxes on it until you pull
the money out and then if you did make
some money and you pull the money out
it'll be taxed at your capital gains
rate rather than your ordinary income
rate so it's even tax advantaged
in that sense
so
good question thanks for joining